[Music]
hey
all right t t uh where are you from
originally where'd you grow up
compass tell me about your family you
grew up with both your parents
yeah went to school
was brought up nice but somehow i end up
bad
tell me about your childhood
well [ __ ] i went
i didn't have no childhood really i mean
i started [ __ ] up when i was like 15.
and i've been [ __ ] up ever since they
tried to raise me right
something wrong so but parents were good
and yeah they were there for you but you
just kind of
went a different direction yeah and uh
so what age were you when you left your
parents house
17 17 and where'd you go from there
job corps i [ __ ] up there
then i went to the military
i got a honorable discharge and
[ __ ] i just been [ __ ] up i don't know
what's wrong
but uh so
so you're now a pimp for some of the
girls here on skid row
yeah one of the girls is candace right
yeah yeah
is that something you saw as a kid you
saw guys doing that in your neighborhood
stuff like that
no what do you think led you down to
that
to this i needed some money
it was out there doing it so i might as
well be they pimp you know
uh what's the arrangement the girls work
for you they bring the money and then
you
do what i break them off you know
they only want dope you know but i give
them money too
uh they stay with me some of them
yeah i went by your tent you've got like
three girls living with you right yeah
what's wrong i think i'm getting tired
i'm trying to get out of downtown you
know
um it's kind of rough
i've been down here like five years yeah
you've been in prison time
yeah what kind of stuff you've been in
driven from sure
robbery attempt to murder
i just got out i've been out for five
years
i got out i did 18 years straight
laundry yeah
do you have kids of your own two girls
two girls
did you raise them well when i went to
prison there was like about
seven and nine and i ain't seen them in
all the years when i got out i tried to
talk to them but they
yeah like they don't know me you know
it was acting like i was a stranger or
something
so i don't talk to them no more
you know i had a place but some girl
burnt it
so i got a place last year i was on in
there for nine days
and uh she burnt it they kicked me out
i'm trying to find another place but
it's hard
yeah so what what what are the what are
the personality traits you need to work
as a pimp i mean you need to
to to have what traits to get a girl to
work for you
uh charisma you gotta have
you know finesse
and you gotta you know treat em right
you know
if they if they treat you right you got
to treat them right
yeah does force or intimidation come
into the picture sometimes
not with me if they don't want to do it
then i ain't gonna trip
you know i ain't gonna turn nobody out
if they're doing it already
you know and what what are the
tracy girl needs to to do this to work
for you
she gotta look good she gotta act right
that's about it
and don't be stealing you know you know
get a man what are you paying for there
won't be no problem you know
what are your plans down the road in the
future do you have anything you'd like
to see happen
well
uh four more months that's my goal to be
out of downtown
and are you using any drugs that are out
here i use a little bit of crystal
i got to stay up
how much are the girls bringing in
tonight
500. how much 500 per girl
yeah wow that's pretty good i don't i
don't keep my girls down here
they ain't gonna make [ __ ] down here
yeah better neighborhoods for making
money right
yeah where are you guys go figueroa and
i go to hollywood
[Music]
a lot of places uh i go to the beach
sometime
to the valley
comes down here ain't nothing but this
i mean if i was a girl i wouldn't i
wouldn't do nothing down here
right yeah you make a fraction of the
money right
then
john ended up kicking your ass taking
the money back and don't give anything
at all you know it's crazy
all right well t thank you so much for
talking to me
all right what'd you do i'm a
photographer i just
i just find these stories down here
interesting
you know everybody's got an interesting
story to tell you you don't go nowhere
else
what do you mean uh the neighborhoods oh
yeah yeah yeah i go all around
i mean i've been down here because it's
just like every time i come down here
there's more interesting stuff like you
just walked into my lab today right this
neighborhood is chock full of
interesting people like you
but one day and then sometimes i go
to other neighborhoods and find
interesting stuff elsewhere too because
there's there's stuff like this going on
all over the country
not just right here on skid row but skid
row does have a ton of it
so i don't have to work too hard i just
show up here and it falls into my lap
but
you know i've been to other places and
what am i doing tonight no i mean do a
lakers game
no what would you i mean what you do in
life you know
oh that's what you've been doing yeah i
support myself shooting advertising
photography you know for for companies
that
need ads and stuff like that that's how
i make money i don't make money doing
this this is
i bleed money doing this but i find it
interesting
so so you making money and just like
giving it away i'm basically giving it
away yeah i mean you don't really need
it
no i mean i have money's money's
important i don't want to give it away
but i don't think you would come in here
for five dollars
[ __ ] if i was death that i would yeah
but but
so i have to end up paying people like
you to come in here and sometimes that
cost me 20 bucks or more
and uh
you know people like you i probably have
to pay quite a bit more than 20. but
but a lot of the heroin addicts that are
out here in the street that are doing
the craziest stuff are happy to come in
here for 20 bucks
and i'm happy to pay him for that and i
had him sign a release and
we do a little talk and i put it on
youtube do people see it
yeah yeah i mean i i'm just i'm very new
at it so it's like
you know i started off with getting like
you know 12 or 15 views a day
and now now it's grown and it's growing
pretty quickly so it's kind of
encouraging to see people kind of
some people can't watch this stuff it's
just too dark it's too
disturbing but other people find it uh
you know i think you can learn a lot
about human nature you can learn
a lot about what's going on with our
society you can find out about
some of the problems that we have as a
country by watching these things
[Music]
you know because it's a it's a comp it's
a complex problem it's racism
it's wealthy inequality it's opportunity
and education inequality it's
it's self-esteem issues it's it's i
think the government
i think the government is causing this
government's a huge part of it you know
because
the black community is so beaten down
like i talked to some of these gang gang
kids and they're like like what options
did you have as a kid
i didn't have any you know when i was a
kid growing up in suburban chicago
well back in our days i don't think we
really had none but
now you know i think
if the young kids if they want to do
something right they got
opportunities and [ __ ] well i mean they
do and they don't
it's still really rough for a lot of
people yeah
right you know in in certain
neighborhoods it's just it's
so yeah so bleak
it's there's so few chances like when i
grew up i was like i could have been a
lawyer a doctor politician i chose
photographer but i could have done
anything
a lot of these kids i talked to were
like they didn't they didn't have a
chance in hell
they didn't know what a photographer
looked like or a doctor or a lawyer they
didn't no
like how would you even do that you know
so so but i see is
there's no hope for the black people no
more that's what i'm saying they don't
have hope
junior high school actually come down on
may
and it was then but i i didn't know
about it
i mean i didn't think it would i mean i
seen people hanging out on the street
sleeping
i didn't think nothing about
homelessness but
[ __ ] it was there you know
and [ __ ] then i did 18 years in prison
and it's still here
oh it's not going to change yeah well
what i'm hoping is by putting out these
videos
maybe creating a little bit of awareness
about how bad it is and
how how tough it is for some people and
how they got that way
like how does a girl end up as a heroin
addict on this or crack addict on the
street
selling selling her body to make a buck
and that's her only you know giving up
her kids
and that's her life and she has no hope
for anything better
nothing no miracle is going to come out
of the woodwork and save her life
because she she's used to this that's
how she yeah a lot of it is the
self-worth that they didn't
ever develop because their parents
treated them like crap or abandoned them
beating them up and all that kind of
stuff they were molested at six years
old they were in foster homes they
they had crap you know i had supportive
parents i had parents that loved me they
still do
you know they were they were consistent
so i had that wonderful
upbringing that a lot of the people i'm
talking to
they wouldn't even know what that looked
like they they have no idea
they don't even know their parents you
know the foster home treated them like
crap
and they ran away from the foster home
as teenagers and they were out in the
street
and what does a young girl do on the
street to make money because she needs
money right
there you go and that that's a terrible
thing that goes on in our society and it
goes on a lot people just would rather
not look at it
so i'm putting out these painful hard to
look at videos people at the top they
know what's going on
well you i think a lot of people just
would rather not look at it pretend it
doesn't happen
and by putting out these videos just
kind of maybe create awareness and
maybe help people what
what i'm hoping because i don't know
that i'm going to save any heroin addict
that's currently an addict
i i don't think they can be saved maybe
there's there's a couple
that somehow resurrect themselves and
rebuild their lives and that's beautiful
to see
but those are rare but what i'm hoping
is by maybe putting out these videos
somebody that's about to have
kids or maybe just had a kid might
decide to like
[ __ ] maybe i should be there for my this
generation is getting worse
that's what i'm saying and what i'm
doing what i hope is that the next
generation might actually
get it together or maybe we'll help them
get to get it together by
having more opportunities for them more
wealth
gets shared less you know by by
you know partially it's going to be less
greed
in the government less greed and society
that might somehow help these
communities get their [ __ ] together well
all the black singers and rappers and
all this [ __ ]
they don't i don't i don't see them
doing that that's what that's awesome
no it's it's it's it's across the board
it's not just white people
yeah it's sad
i'm not sure sometimes i think we can
make a difference and sometimes i get
i get discouraged but it's going on you
know
and it goes on in other cities too
everybody thinks it's just skid row it's
in chicago
it's in detroit they've got skateboards
in every city every city i've been to
every state in the country and i see
different versions of this
in north dakota in florida in texas
in mississippi it goes on all over take
your pick it just looks a little
different and it's in different
neighborhoods and some
some are worse than others this is one
of the worst ones um
it's a lot of homeless out here because
everybody comes from other states
the weather is great and the support is
here you want food look at the nice
clothes you get to wear you got
those from from one of the missions
right yeah or people handing out clothes
or
food or you know there's even a place to
take a shower down the street
i don't i don't even need an admission
yeah you can get it
yeah i'll buy my food yeah as i'm saying
well you're you've found a place
a way to make money so you can buy and
get what you need but
but even if you were unwilling to do
[ __ ] for yourself
you can get clothing you can get a tent
and get
you can get [ __ ] uh i don't i don't
sleep in the mission
i can't do it i can't do it
yeah well it's encouraging that you
actually want to get your ass out of
here because
most people just don't even have to the
wherewithal to do that and plus i still
got my family
you know um
they trying to find a place they helped
me and stuff they knew i'm down here
yeah well family is a huge part of this
whole
thing and when the family breaks apart
as it does from
95 percent of the people i've talked to
then everything else falls apart shoot
if i didn't have no family i'd still
keep
going i still keep pushing i wouldn't
break down and then
i just keep rolling you know well not
everyone gets broken by these terrible
childhoods some of the some people
actually pull their [ __ ] together they
work harder they focus and they build
their
life kind of on their own all by
themselves on their own
there's all kinds of stories and there's
there's people that have done great
things with nothing and there's people
who have
given up and just fallen down here
this which is the bottom of the barrel
even though they had great support from
their families and
there's all kinds of stories but i'm
just creating some awareness
of all these different stories there's a
video go talk to the uh
the governor or the president of
somebody yeah well
maybe somebody one day will see these
these things and
it'll wake somebody up a little bit
because it seems like they don't care
that you didn't have to do anything and
you get to keep your money what would
you do
i mean they have other countries yes
they have other countries before they
help us
they do yeah and and
this place is is starting to become like
a
central america or something the whole
place is full of mexicans
you know [ __ ] that's all i eat is
mexican food
but uh they they got it together though
you know
because they look out for each other i
know that
families families are a huge part of it
that's why one of the questions that
i always ask is like tell me about your
family because that seems to be like a
huge
factor in
somebody having the strength to
persevere and get through life
well shoot i had it bad down here one
time
shoot and i called my brother i said man
i'm tired of living on the street
he said i'm gonna try to find your place
it took like [ __ ] about a month
he called me so you ready i said yeah
he said give me this i'm gonna come get
you next week he found me a place
but [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up it wasn't my
fault
and it was i liked it i was in a receded
uh then i lost that place
and i ended up down here and then i just
said [ __ ] it
and then they found me another place
and then i i let some girl come over and
then she [ __ ] the place up
know definitely burnt down yeah
so i'm back down here and it's hard it's
good it seems like it's harder now to
find a place
because i was paying 800 there now all
the places i'm
looking at online it's like
11 12 13 14 you know
i don't know how i'm gonna do it but
oh no but i'm gonna get out of here
i'm gonna get out of here four more
months
i'm gonna let you know all right four
more months good for you i'd love to see
that
i'd love to see that i'd love to talk to
you after you do it too all right
have you back all right well thank you
for talking to me
good luck with everything